it's okay to be different it's okay to
not look like a normal person it's okay
to get outside your comfort zone and be
courageous even if people don't like it
along is positive then you should press
forward with it my name is Isaiah
Griffin and I'm a bodybuilder when I was
1718 I developed this condition called
keloids basically they wanted your body
over heals itself started as bumps every
now and then that will burst open that
look like regular acne then they started
to just connect and make the web
basically on my chest in earlier stages
of having my keloids honestly didn't
understand it or how to feel about it I
wasn't in a mirror so much there won't
be times where I would just wash my face
turn the lights off
mentally mess with my confidence I had a
depression from it but mainly weren't
about focus on what other people think
kind of been in a shoe but slowly but
surely I just started wearing tank tops
in a gym to where I will feel like I'm
overcoming whatever is peddling on
outside or inside there was something
new something completely different I
want to work towards being a world
champion but this journey is more about
self-improvement more than it is
receiving any medals anything being a
champion it is nice but I need to see
the real meaning what I'm doing when I
see myself in the mirror now just see
myself and love myself all the past the
scars and just see a person who doesn't
want to accept the norm it's African
proverb if there's no enemy within the
enemy outside can do us no harm
[Music]
[Music]